foreign
let's go to Chrissy in Boston what's up
Chrissy
Hi how are you good how are you oh I'm
I'm good I can't believe I'm talking to
you I was just thinking I can't believe
I'm talking to you that's so good
so what's up my first one is say thank
you for all that you do I listened to
your show regularly and has really
helped me you are thank you for being
kind
um it's so easy for me to get off the
air and I don't really talk to anybody
I'm like staring at a camera right now
just pretending I'm looking at you and
um it's often easy to wonder like what
am I doing with my life and so thank you
so much for your kindness I'm grateful
awesome so my question is short is how
do I forgive my parents
um
and to give you some context um it's
like that's like I'm gonna set this
Grenade on the coffee table and I'm
gonna pull it down and they're all gonna
sit down and watch it yeah so uh what
does that mean tell me what that means
yeah so um me and my husband wanted to
start to grow our family and
unfortunately I was giving the diagnosis
of block two
y'all starting IVF yeah we're starting
our IVF Journey so sorry if I have two
years um and um I'm so thankful for
science but I'm I'm really angry
um but this is another thing that I have
to do by myself in life
um my parents have always been sure my
basic needs were met but growing up I
felt like I was a referee in their
relationship with their arguments which
most of them were about my mother being
irresponsible with money or my dad being
drunk
um I've worked really hard to have a
good self-esteem and confidence about
myself I'm really good with money I
think before I speak I'm a good listener
and lastly if you need a friend I try to
be the person who others can call on I
don't ask for much in life but I've
always wanted to be a mom
and with this diagnosis I feel like this
is just a slap in the face that after
being such a caregiver during my
childhood that I yet again have to do
another hard thing and it feels so it
feels really lonely yeah
I'm sorry
thank you
um
who's walking with you in this season
who's walking with me
who have you told what you just told me
who have you already told that to beside
your husband
foreign
okay so you gotta rent a friend who's
like a like a person in your life
um
I have I have friends um hold on hold on
hold on hold on who have you told what
you just told me
I'm going through IVF but not all the
um I guess all of those things there you
go
so you have said like it just I want you
to go back and hit like the 15 second
back button a few times when you first
hear this call okay in the very in your
opening sentences you said things like I
feel and I think and I've tried
that is that is the language of somebody
who was responsible who was the
irresponsible adult in her household
that is the language of somebody who
grew up with an addict
an erratic parent somebody who grew up
in chaos
and the reason that's the language of
somebody who grew up in chaos is you
don't know what it even feels like to be
whole or more importantly to trust
yourself and let me change your language
for you because I can tell you within 30
seconds of hearing from you
you did
and you are not you think and you feel
you are a world-class friend
you're a world-class daughter and you're
gonna be a
incredible mom
okay
yep that all of that starts with you
trusting yourself and it's something
you're gonna have to practice because
you've never
you've never been able to do it the
trust you had in yourself was that you
could make sure everybody was okay so
you could play the game so you could
survive Fair
yeah yeah
and you shouldn't have to be going
through this alone
but at this point this is where I'm
gonna this is hard language I know
you have to choose to not be lonely
anymore
which means you have to open yourself up
to potentially being hurt really bad
again
by telling your friends I'm heartbroken
and I'm sad I'm scared and one of them
is going to say something stupid
one of them's gonna hurt your feelings
one of them's gonna say something dumb
what I'm gonna be like oh yeah well my
journey was and you're gonna be like how
about you take your journey and shove it
up right it doesn't matter
and they're going to screw it up and
you're gonna have to continue to be
vulnerable and choose to not be lonely
is that fair
yeah no that that's definitely fair I
definitely
um
struggle with
um I always feel like when I'm talking
with friends with something's going on
with my life it feels like I'm overly
asserting myself or or or putting my
problems onto others that's because the
people who were by Design supposed to
teach you how to carry problems
gave you theirs
yeah
yeah he's a young kid you've heard my
bricks in the backpack instead of
parents walking alongside their children
and holding their bricks with them and
teaching them the weight and how heavy
things are age appropriately your
parents handed you all their cinder
blocks and said here kid you carry this
and so now basic I need help basic will
you just cry with me basic hey will you
bring chips and queso over because I
don't want to get out of bed
um that feels like a burden
instead of just life
yeah you know what I mean
no yeah no that that makes perfect can I
say something provocative
yeah I don't think you're mad at your
parents
I think you're mad at your body
that too
I think they're the easy Target because
they were they were so
um
they did such a bad job with you
um and it's okay to be really mad at
your body
the one thing man can I just have this
one thing God can I have one thing
yeah it feels like I was gonna get like
something you know I feel like I've been
a good person and
I don't know I feel like I've done a lot
of my I've done a lot of heart stuff in
my life and I just want it the one thing
I've always wanted to be easy yeah and
it's not and oh and you see you see
every family member getting somebody
knocked up and you see every 16 year old
with unwanted right you see it all over
the place right oh yeah and it just yeah
puts gasoline on that fire
yeah and it just feels like why me yes
and so let me tell you the question
why me
is a question that doesn't have an
answer
but it's an invitation to all sorts of
mental and spiritual and physical
um dysregulation
okay
of all the I'll tell people all day long
I'll tell you be super pissed at your
body be upset I have a friend who really
really struggled with infertility and
she was like I didn't have a period
every month of my freaking life
since I was 11 until now to not be like
it was she's a she was cracking me up
and we were both like laughs crying
together
um like be upset at the whole thing
you have been living in a world where
he
oh man
I'm gonna say it this way you've been
living in a world where you woke up and
the score was already a hundred to zero
and you were losing
right
right and so you thought I can put 500
points in this bucket and it will
balance out cosmically and there's few
things more terrifying than realizing
that nature and the world don't work
that way
that instead of stacking the deck with
kindness and generosity and well-being
and peace making not peacekeeping
peacemaking because it's just right and
because it it gives us a simpler
day-to-day present
it's easy to start stacking the deck
thinking that it's gonna there's gonna
be an Roi on it for us it's going to pay
us back someday
yeah right and it's just not how it
works and that's devastating when we
realize that
so what I would tell you is don't don't
spin the energy the one thing I'm going
to tell you feel your feelings man be
upset be raged out be angry be
frustrated weep bitterly
yeah put to bed the question why me
instead say
why me or not not why me instead ask
yourself what am I gonna do next
what am I gonna do next
because it is I shouldn't even like um I
guess I I'm just so
upset with my
hair I mean I I know I have to separate
the two
um my being mad at my body but I I guess
I don't understand or I'm I'm struggling
with but now that I'm starting this
journey that these feelings about my
parents have like risen to the top like
it like it's keeping me up at night like
just thinking about the chaos that I was
raised in and how because it's not fair
it's not fair
yeah because you want this so badly and
you know what kind of parent you're
gonna be and they just got it it fell
from the sky for them and they they were
flipping about it and they abused it
yeah and every second you spend thinking
about them
is a choice to be less joyful in your
present
they're not worth your your time they're
not worth the space in your soul
they're not worth even considering in
the same thought pattern as this future
baby you're gonna hold one day
yeah they're just it's not
and here's the deal your body's trying
to keep you safe because you weren't for
a long time
and so when things got scary and things
got hard and things got frightening
we went back to the old ways the old
lessons that we had learned
and you've been a parent since you were
very very young
yeah
yeah and now it's time to let the little
kid off the hook she needs to be done
being a parent now
right okay yeah
yeah so you hear me say this all the
time it's one of the most therapeutic
exercises in the the science literature
bit Bears it out but more importantly
just the people that I interact with on
a daily basis
have you sat down and written that
letter to your parents yet
that you'll never give them
you need you need to do that and it's
probably going to be three different
letters
and one of them will be
how dare you I can't believe what
happened
the second one will be
it's not all bad here's what also what
you gave me
because of you here's who I am today
and the third one is
here's what you missed and here's what
you're gonna miss
because me Chrissy from Boston freaking
Massachusetts
spending some time at some Harvard bars
all right of course best city hey
um it's a close second to Houston but uh
Chrissy from Boston drinking a laga
listen
our sports teams do always win though
just saying I mean you'll finish last
place in the Astros in the World Series
right now but it's cool we can talk
about that later
hey the Astros beat the Yankees can we
all agree on that that was good that was
good
um but hey we're moving on
now you got a new Journey now it's about
okay cool
um my body didn't line up how I thought
I'm gonna grieve it I thought this
picture was gonna look like this and it
didn't
I'm gonna be heartbroken for a season
and then
I'm gonna take care of myself because
I'm a person who takes care of my body
and I'm gonna eat right and I'm going to
exercise and my husband and I are gonna
have tons of fun practicing this thing
that we're doing because it's awesome
and I'm gonna trust my doctors and can I
give you one piece of wisdom
um on the IVF Journey
of course have a Finish Line in mind
before you go down that road
here's how much money we're going to
spend we're gonna try this many times
there's so many eggs we're gonna
fertilize this is this is our plan and
we don't go past it without
several months of hard thinking and
prayer time if you're a person of faith
and wisdom seeking because it can become
its own nightmarish Journey you're gonna
wake up and be 200 Grand in the hole and
it's gonna be a mess
yes okay yeah
um and if the day comes
um
one of the ways I keep myself well is
um I always always am out on the
optimistic side of things things could
turn out really really great and I
always hold very Loosely they might not
yeah they might not
and so make peace in your heart make
peace inside make peace with your
husband make peace with your friends and
your community
that motherhood may look different
they look different I don't think I
don't think it is I think the ivf's
gonna work I do I don't know why maybe
I'm just putting it out in the universe
but I think I think it's going to work
um but if it doesn't
it won't be because you did something
wrong
or didn't do it do enough good to
balance out the other side of the Ledger
and it won't be because your parents
were extra extra me
sometimes things just are
sometimes things just are
then we own what is we acknowledge
reality and then we ask ourselves that
terrifying question what are we going to
do next hang on the line my friend
um I'm going to send you a couple things
now what I'm going to send you on your
past change your future read that book
um it's talking about healing from
trauma and
um it's got some some waste it's going
to walk you through the letter writing
and I'm going to send you questions for
humans couples Edition I want you and
your husband to stay connected during
your IVF Journey Don't let the
um don't let the metrics and the numbers
and the holding your breath pull you all
apart y'all stay connected as you can
okay thank you so much for being brave
and for walking through your journey
with us
um
when you get pregnant let us know let us
be the second to know
and we'll tell the world